let's look at the stuff for today we
started off talking about utilitarianism
as a moral theory and we noted that it
was a kind of hedonism so heathenism
beings that focused on pleasure and pain
as the good and the bad free human
beings you can understand these sort of
being flip sides at the same coin right
you all know what it is you all know
what it's like to experience pleasure
the experience comes pleasure in your
life you all know what it's like to
experience pain sometimes the
alleviation of the pain can actually
bring a pleasure sometimes they leave
the reduction or the interference or
taking away the pleasure can bring a
pain think about when you have the
pleasure of a friendship and your friend
gets to go away somewhere now you feel
the pain of missing them right or think
about the pain that you feel some of you
may not have eaten breakfast or you may
you know you're going to feel pleasure
pleasure being filthy and this is an
important part of life and then hand
pleasure are Bad's and goods every moral
theory that we've looked at so far
acknowledges that what's unique about
utilitarianism and about hedonism in
general as it says these are the only
real events all the other goods are
reducible to these so think about all
the other things that we value like
actually before the beginning of the
semester one of the things that you guys
said was relationships family friends
maybe even your teammates
you enjoy being in classes with with
fellow students or something like that
you enjoy other people you enjoy their
company right that could be a good thing
well utilitarianism says you like that
because of the pleasure it brings and
those other people want to be around you
if you bring them pleasure and guess
what if you stop bringing them pleasure
they're not going to want to be around
you and you know you didn't want to set
this in different ways we saw this when
we looked at Aristotle you know you can
have a plot be kind of a friendship
where one person is getting pleasure the
other person is getting remember
usefulness or utility they're going to
get some other fat plungers so if I pay
you to hang around with me you enjoy
getting money right anybody here doesn't
like getting money why do you like to
get it getting money
a cashless economy lucky we have credit
cards right but you know we need to take
the money out you don't like rub it on
your face and say oh that feels so good
right of smelling or chew I yeah it
doesn't bring pleasure you can't I mean
some people do crazy things like they
fill up a room with money and then they
jump in it like Uncle Scrooge duck
things but you know that's not real you
can't actually get any pleasure of money
you get pleasure out of what it brings
you write utility businesses
you don't know concert unless you know
like open mic night they're doing it for
free you buy it to get their p.m. is up
there they enjoy playing and they
probably enjoy having you out in the
audience but they don't really care
whether it's you know mr. Barinholtz or
mr. Singh or mr. Saab well they don't
care whether it's you know one of these
guys unless they're connected to them
all these years a bunch of faces and you
know a lot of people screaming and
they're providing pleasure why are they
doing it because they're getting paid
likewise there's people who alleviate or
pain right there's doctors good example
doctors nurses emergency technicians all
these people whose role is we call
caretaking
at what hospice people who fit into that
there's assistance all the way down to
the communities members they're all
important because they alleviate pain is
a bad thing
relationships are very important often I
acknowledge nothing to me from
traditional ethics what else it is
important to you your you guys talked
about career path very understandable
you're all upperclassmen you're all good
college you're all preparing for some
sort of career that you're going to
engage in I think all of you are in the
career path that you're in because you
think you're going to like it right I
hope none of you are going into
something and saying God and I hate this
but it's going to bring me a ton of
money so I'm going to do this for 40
years heating it every single day but
having money nobody is in that in that
book that's good what do you learn what
do you say and you don't like it oh
that's to lay out because you're gonna
have to you know figure out eventually
that's what you want to stay I hope that
you can find something in it that will
gratify that will bring you pleasure
that's what you're hoping for yeah so
maybe you just haven't found that that
thing yeah maybe this your junior year
senior year maybe maybe when you go to
grad school because I mean every subject
that you go to study there's something
very interesting about otherwise people
wouldn't waste of their time developing
there's things you can get hooked into
and your career could be like that I
mean your career could just be a way to
make money well right but your career
could also be something that brings you
pleasure
if you enjoy you know if you go to med
school because you have a actually
killing people and you become a good
doctor because you like doing what you
do and it will bring you pleasure if
you're studying criminal justice because
you have an interest in issues of
criminality and what we do with these
people and how to make a better society
and you find yourself able to do
something with that that will bring you
pleasure
you know these things will bringing pain
to that school they're bringing a lot of
pain because you're gonna be up all
night studying things constantly
cramming working for lower wages once
you're an intern for a while what
ultimately it's supposed to be a
pleasure right criminal justice if
you're stuck inside a maximum-security
prison which are you know pretty awful
places any food is good in the officers
dining club you know I remember what I
was talking about this the other day I
used to eat at the officers dining table
yeah the food was just like one step up
from what the prisoners reading which
wasn't very good either and one of the
things that used to drive me nuts
but you have to speak any and every once
in a while they've run out of spaghetti
sauce so you know what they would cut it
with what's that that would have been
better because at least ketchup is more
or less tomato paste made barbecue sauce
how do you make spaghetti oh well you
boil it too much sort of institutional
is that too it's possible that's the
least of your problems in prison right
that food so if you're working in the
criminal justice system there's going to
be some game for you but there hopefully
there will also be pleasure if it's what
you really like to do any of the other
careers that you're going into should
ultimately bring you some sort of
pleasure the Aristotle talked about this
Plato's talked about this in terms of
the Kennedy satisfaction that goes
beyond pleasure in terms of virtue right
virtuous behavior but a utilitarian
would say virtue is that which brings
you pleasure and also brings other
people pleasure
so being you know we hit about the
virtues that we talked about a lot this
semester being a just person right
justice if you're really a just person
it brings you pleasure to do it and if
you're not all that just it'll at least
keep you out of trouble so you want to
counter the pain of punishment and if
you're just person you great pleasure to
other people right you don't you don't
steal their stuff you don't take more
than your fair share and you don't treat
them wrongly you're not bringing them
pains you may actually be alleviating
everything let's either the kind of just
person who actually like evens things
out you see somebody being treated for
at least so you say I'm gonna go out of
my way to treat them well what are you
doing you're giving them pleasure or
taking away some of their pain right all
of you want to be respected all of you
want to be treated like a person who
matters not be treated like dirt whereas
hop said you know with contempt
why well Beth would say what this is
really about is a different kind of
pleasure it's not like physical pleasure
so I you know sitting down and having a
nice meal we're going out for a beer or
listening to music that you like it's a
different kind of more internal pleasure
but you know when somebody respects you
you've done a good job and somebody
gives you a compliment and they say wow
nice job you did a really great job with
this thing or that thing you put a lot
of effort into it but not only you can
put in a lot of effort I can see you've
got some talent at this that gives you a
kind of pleasure we're you know as it is
the thing then that would make Tillet
arianism functionable is that you also
care about the pleasure of others at the
same time because yes that's that's
where utilitarianism is going beyond
just ordinary humans now you consider
everybody else's pleasure and pain as at
least as important as your own if you
were an egoist you could you could care
about other people's pleasure in pain
like I you know for instance let's say
I'm Keith Lewis
so I'm ultimately just self-interested
does that mean that I wouldn't care at
all about how you feel or think yeah as
a class well maybe my self-image is tied
up with you know being a professor right
yeah I can't feel like a good professor
that my students aren't doing well so
then I have to care about my students
but not because they matter in
themselves not because you have value on
your own but just because you're you
know an extension of me
now that would be an ego stick and your
pleasure paint right oh just a second I
could care about your pleasure or pain
you know but only insofar as it affects
mine because maybe I don't like to think
of myself as the kind of person who
inflicts pain you know so maybe I like
to think of myself as a great pleasure
bringer I can care about that because it
affects me or I could care about that
because you actually because your your
pleasure and are important because
you're another being like me
utility rhiness was saying the latter
that everybody's pleasure everybody's
pain oh that's a good question what
about something that brings both
pleasure and pain
so Bentham would say you have to give
the balance these out against each other
remember last class we looked at how we
have a tally these sort of things so
let's think of a classic example going
out on the town and getting really drunk
that brings a lot of pleasure right
that's why people like drink because not
only is there the the sheer physical
thing you know the whatever it is that
you're drinking hopefully tastes good
though maybe you know when you're first
starting out it doesn't and then there's
the physical sensation of intoxication
that people like and then there's all
the other things that they come from it
you know why else do people drink why do
we serve alcohol at social functions
exactly that's what they call the social
number because after like a couple
drinks people start to interact with
each other this little reviews internet
in different ways that they would
ordinarily they get a little bit more
friendly now if you give them a lot of
drinks then they're probably in trouble
and they start falling down the stairs
you know like getting at each other or
getting in fights or things like that so
just you know if you want to give them a
lot of drinks
that's why cash bar but now so those are
all pleasures right what are the pains
that afterwards there's sometimes you
know very soon in oh okay a very long
term yeah you could become an alcoholic
that's not my style yeah okay would be
if you drink too much and you get into
hangover or get into a fight like
because it's two different possibilities
one is you know more organic and pretty
likely depending on how much you drink
you're probably not going to feel good
the next day because the alcohol is
actually poisoned right yeah makes us
feel good at first and then keep
drinking and drinking and drinking
starts suppressing some of your bodily
functions those you know fix your
hangover drinks they have the things in
them that your body is now missing
because it's the alcohol is you know
foster system or bonded with it or
catalyzed so there's a pain that comes
with that and then you you could have
all these other possible pain you wake
up next to somebody in the morning you
have no idea how you got there and you
look at all what's this you know or are
you drive your car home and you crash
and wake up
you know I knew a guy that's happened to
it was because he was drunk he was just
sleep-deprived he woke up with his trunk
upside-down luckily his seatbelt in and
just hanging from the ceiling lights out
till the night no idea where he was or
what did he happen just that he was
upside down and he got pretty yeah that
would be you know pain more
psychological pain if you drink a lot
long-term they eventually brain function
so there would be one of those cases
where you balance out the pleasures and
pains and some people might say well you
know the drinking isn't even worth of
that you know if it's gonna lead to all
these these effects and you can add into
it other things let's stay for it since
you're in a society that condemns
drinking there are some religions that
are very much against use of alcohol if
you're a middle-eastern let's say you're
in Saudi Arabia you're not supposed to
drink so if you do they can get you in a
lot of trouble they all go to Bahrain or
let's say you're in a town full of
people that look down on drinkers and
you're the one going out to the bar and
it brings you some social disapproval
well that would be a panicking
with net any of you like people looking
down on you saying bad things about you
probably not right that never hurts your
feelings doesn't it I know we don't like
to admit that people who refuse but let
me almost be honest about it people say
bad things about you you don't like that
do you
that's a basic function of X so that
could make that pleasure no longer worth
the the pain that it brings if the pain
becomes more than the pleasure then you
probably shouldn't engage in that action
that utilitarian would say well we're
going to look at today is some of the
other things that go along with this and
Bentham talks about intention the
intention of an act the motive and then
dispositions so before we looked at just
acts by themselves and the act is good
or bad depending on its and what is
utility it's the propensity to bring
about pleasure or to reduce pain the Act
would have negative utilities if it has
a tendency to produce pain so my calling
you a bunch of aims for 18 years of
class that would be an act with negative
utility and we could look at it just in
terms of the individual being affected
like if I single off mr. Gucci and I say
you're a terrible student get out of my
classroom you shouldn't be here why
you're even at Marist or something else
things like that right he should
probably feel bad as a result unless you
realize
which Caixin actually brings him
pleasure laughing if you thought it was
really being honest about they were
bringing the pain
now there's two people involved in this
right there's gun let's bring him pain
but let's say I'm a sadist and I enjoy
getting pleasure up and ready I get
pleasure out of imposing paint on other
people well maybe that would be a good
actor because if my pleasure always gets
pain Wow pleasure to tell that person
well if your pain is less than my
pleasure then even if I can until
tearing it would be okay well because
the neck balance would be positive right
putting here as soon as then your my
opinion would have to be greater than
your pleasure we can also think about it
this way how would you all feel by a
single lot of students by a single lot
of students in the class to start
relating them front will you enjoy it
would you feel uncomfortable
they didn't make me feel uncomfortable
would it make you feel
this oh you need to do your homework you
know you really should get the stuff in
on time things you know yeah but are you
yelling and cursing and swearing and
yeah let's make it no I'm not using
swear words you know talking about their
parents and you know all sorts of things
like that I would be appalled you know
okay that goes beyond describing yeah I
feel like being a Paul that would be
other people's paint so if I single out
one student and I'm on the stateís I'm
getting pleasure from the act he's
getting paid from the act but the rest
of you are all good pain from the act
that's a bad no fury Attila Tyrion
everybody is pleasures in penis yeah
that's what's distinctive that
utilitarianism as opposed to egoistic
hedonism everybody's everybody who could
be affected but you know if it's mine
yelling at mister Micucci we're not
really concerned about what the class
next door thinks would be concerned
about what you guys would think so
that's looking at things just in terms
of the yeah
now the think in terms of intentions and
what Bentham tells us about intentions
he says an act can be unintentional or
can be intentional
it can be unintentional in different
ways and remember we talked about this
with Aristotle are we responsible for
everything that we do are the currently
responsible or there's some
is that absolve us of responsibility
do you remember walking with the things
that absolved us for Aristotle where
there were two main conditions that
could get you off the hook
one was how often they actually made the
mistake yeah they had a good pattern of
being virtuous and they virtue in the
bytes you said it will responsible for
so encounters are it looks we're just
looking at individual acts now so you
know you're looking at a person doing
something you want to say are they
responsible for it or not there were two
things that aerosol said that get you I
think about you know what you would
excuse we're talking about what make
something involuntary right what what
are the things that actually makes
something involved what's that
the force or whatever so called impulse
in that if I make you do something that
in a certain way you're not responsible
for it or like let's say I reject you
with a drug intoxicated now you go out
and you crash your car
well you're not responsible for that
right because I'm the one who did it to
you ignorant right if you're not aware
some of the particular circumstances so
you know the example of you throw a ball
at somebody and you don't realize they
don't know how to catch and you didn't
realize that the balls actually you know
they're hard and full glad I hit some
headed their dad we didn't mean that
happen right he was throwing him all of
them you were ignorant to some of the
circumstances or you reveal the secrets
that you weren't supposed to reveal at
all but you you thought the other person
already knew about that would be a case
of ignorance and in those sorts of cases
we say that the person didn't intend the
consequence to happen
well Bentham talks about intentions as
well and he says acts can be intentional
at you know any particular stage and
he's not so interested in that he's more
interested in whether intentions are
good or bad and this is going to tie in
with with dispositions and with motives
because oftentimes we talk about an act
as being good or bad depending on the
intention right if in fact I intended to
throw the ball at the person I thought
let's make this snowball instead you
guys all remember when your kids throw
snowballs and snowball fights they
coming oh my kids do that and there were
a couple things that people would do
that were sort of off limits do you
remember those sort of things and make
it into a nice well we're supposed to
use ice right and you were supposed to
put rocks
you told the secrets why did you tell it
with the intention of making the other
person angry you told a secret
why because you wanted to protect
somebody you wanted to bring them in
you threw snowball that have a rock in
it that you didn't know the rock was in
there you just scooped it up and some
gravel that you deliberately put a rock
in the snowball because you wanted to
get that kid who's been bugging you all
week and teach them a lesson that's a
very different intention isn't it you
put a rock in the snowball because the
other kid actually was throwing rocks at
you that's a different intention right
and we can say as some of these
intentions are good and some of these
intentions are bad can't because I said
what about negligence you know he or
just want to thank you
what usually goes along with that is the
presumption that they should have been
somebody's been all texting other on
their phone and they drive over a
pedestrian well they shouldn't watch it
ro doesn't think they wonder if they
were driving and so I want to get some
people running people over which I think
has been remained that's a very
different intention than what's going on
with negligence I guess in terms of
negligence what you would have to say is
the person's intention doesn't even
match up with what actually takes place
they're intending to get rid of their
emails them so something differently
says it's frequently hear men speak of a
good intention of the at attention the
goodness and badness of a man's
intention and it says that's pretty
important but what does it actually mean
he says strictly speaking nothing can be
said to be good or bad but either in
itself what can be good or bad in itself
only pain or pleasure or on account of
its effects which is utility so a
person's intention Bentham says has to
be judged in terms of its utility so
it's not exactly an intention it's the
result of it
yeah that's a good point the
consequences that they are trying to
bring about the consequences that we say
they may intent so the student who
the kid move is the first one the one
who starts all the trouble who gets a
big rock what's it over the snowball
fight and then throws it get some other
kid in the head that would be a bad
intention why would it be a bad
intention dizzy wanted to hurt somebody
okay what's wrong with that bless you
bring you something actually you know
they like dirty people
it sounds like you know so far I'm a
hole it's a positive act they did in
fact hurt so I hit him in the head
what's what's the bad part of that
attention the other person is down the
field
yeah sure some of you experience that as
kids we've got Rock fights I do I got my
I got underneath my eyebrow we were
college kids do all the crazy stuff we
said I wish they'd actually play again
we felt really good on school boards and
we get sticks and garbage can lids
thanks we'd skate around and try to get
each other of course that would be the
end of the game for that day really
stupid to do why does it brings about a
lot of pain right watch it
you've all heard that expression if it's
buckets there's all the fun and games
until somebody gets hurt okay well
that's what Bentham is talking about
what's being intended is that somebody
be hurt and could there be any other bad
consequences to somebody like rocks
oh yeah good point because you know we
see somebody doing something that's a
little bit you know that looks like a
good idea or they did it therefore I
should get to do it or well the Tory
rocks at me I'd better accept that as
well so it could bring about many other
consequences which are on the whole way
out that's all that makes it a bad
intention if you say something to
another person about their appearance
you could why would you say something
change it so they don't just say that no
it looks fun but and then they go out
and the dress doesn't really look that
great yeah the best answer to that is to
change the subject
anytime you get a question like that I
think you've all seen that commercial
with Dave yeah you might say yes or you
might say yeah I really gotta wear that
are you because why because you're
concerned that it will bring them like
this so that could be a good intention
all right you're trying to prevent how
could it be if the only pain you're
concerned about it yourself like you say
I did well I said well I didn't want to
tell you that dress look bad because I
didn't want you mad at me and then my
intention
be myself not necessarily way the other
person am I was thinking they were like
it's all connected I got walking like
that because you're you know if they're
pleasure matters as much as yours that
means that your pleasure matters as much
as as theirs it's not like you were what
else I mean you say stuff about people's
appearance just to hurt time I'll do
that all the time right there's a whole
fashion industry that has a dark side
sort of based on people John rivers
she's hired specifically to say to me
and things about about people when they
walk the red carpet they bring a lot of
other people so what makes an intention
good or bad is what the consequences are
are the consequences on the holes
designed to bring about pleasure or to
relieve pain or are they designed to
cause pain or pleasure
medicine is a good example for this sort
of stuff why do we give people medicines
that you know at least in the past used
to taste bad or which sometimes have
they had side effects or you know give
them operations which are very painful
why do we do that sort of stuff
that's imposing paint exactly yeah this
could be a putting up a benefit you look
at in terms of cost-benefit analysis
what is the cost of the person perhaps a
lot of pain what is the benefit the fact
that they're going to be out of more
pain later or they made
experience pleasure because of a good
example my birth moment just kind of
operation on her back two days ago and
why did she have it well they tried all
these other remedies you know some
people did their back hurts she was in
an accident a long time ago something
what about clauses are alive so they try
all sorts of remedies Chris they trying
to give you shots and a cortisone reduce
swelling and all that and then
eventually they have to operate when
they're offering it either cut you open
that's painful I think of course they
put you under you have a stutter right
but when you when you when they
anesthetic wears a lot now you feel the
pain again but why because it relieves
more pain and I can actually produce the
possibility of pleasure so medicine when
it's doing what it's supposed to do the
intention behind it is good right
could medicine be used for bad hands
there are some doctors who have been
employed to keep people alive awake and
conscious so they could be tortured by
drug cartels the intention there is
clearly quite bad right that's you're
not actually alleviating pain to
alleviate pain you're alleviating pain
for a moment so that you could put the
person in even more pain keep them awake
so you can we can make them feel even
worse that would be a bad intention for
somebody right but how do you tell
whether something is a good intention or
not you have to look at the likely
consequences and the consequences could
could be changing depending on
so there's no intention that by itself
isn't automatically cleared after that
likewise he says motives a motive is
something like an intention but it's
something a bit broader he says a motive
is substantially nothing more than a
pleasure in operating a certain manner
it says pleasure is in itself a good
even setting aside immediately from
paying the only good pain isn't evil
and this alike is true but sort of pain
and Mister pleasure it follows therefore
immediately and uncontested Lee there's
no such thing as any sort of motive that
is in itself a satellite it all depends
on whether the motive brings about anger
pleasure and what does he mean by it
motives he thinks about things like he
calls a tammany but we would call it
friendship right your friendships that
you have those are motives you do the
things that you do with your friends or
towards your friends because that's what
it is to be a friend honor to be a
moment you want people to look up to you
religion you know you're a religious
person and your faith teaches that you
should do X Y Z you feel better when you
do X Y Z you feel bad when you don't do
it
bad person screwing up that can be a
motive there's all different possible
ones
money's our motive right we do a lot of
things that we do for for money success
can be a moment liking a person could be
a motive disliking a person can be a
motive if you really dislike the person
what do you want to do to feel some pain
right now no motive in and of itself
that them says is good or bad it all
depends on whether that motive tends to
bring about pleasure pain not just for
you but for everybody concerned so he
says it's common to speak of the actions
as proceeding from good or bad motives a
lot of people want to judge reverses a
lot of people look at it this way
Aristotle for example would be somebody
like this virtue ethics with you how do
you tell well in part you look at the
motive when we get to count a couple
weeks from now he's gonna look only at
the moment Aristotle would say you also
have to look at the reaction itself on
the structure of the action but some
people say you look solely at the
motives and the motive is good then the
action is if the motive is bad the
action has been even if it brings about
good consequences if it starts with a
bad motive it would be a
right so if your motivation was hatred
of another person let's say for example
how many of you would be somebody that's
gonna be taken that person today or you
don't even necessarily hate them
Kim jong-il North Korea is probably the
closest thing totalitarian country
you've ever done you know research into
it you see that it makes many other
places look like like paradises just
with the sheer amount of misery imposed
on this country just like its data
before it and he'll probably do the same
thing so let's say you could get rid of
this tyrant then your motive was
actually to get rid of the time let's
say you know they snuck you at the CIA
don't even think right good more even
though you know it's taking a human life
what if it threw the country into chaos
even worse categorize that's not what
you intended right that would be a
byproduct of it would be a consequence
left and if you think that motives are
the most important thing you would say
that's a good action even if it turns
out to be had consequences well let's
take a medical exam right there are many
cases where a doctor will prescribe
something and it adds up having they
have consequences but the doctor didn't
intend for those bad consequences to
take place
the motive was actually bad of healing
the patients this is you know what the
medical profession does and the way that
it does it is by prescribing you know
either medications or operations or
things like that it could have bad
consequences but that's not what the
whole
give us the ideas to actually believe to
improve people's quality of life
that's what medicine is about so this is
the action actually matters it just
suddenly the motive like matter that's a
good question
it depends on the moral theory and the
reason I'm putting this up you're going
for utilitarianism ah that's where we
get to free utility rien it's not the
boat not even the action itself this is
mo counsel knows the consequences
because the consequences are a pleasure
hey the action is how pain or pleasure
is produced and the motive is the reason
why the action is engaged in so you know
if having people pursuit well as a
motive well oftentimes we look at we
look down on people who pursue wealth
only so the greedy the heavens the he
said the most important part is an
intention that is an intention matter
all the manages the consequence the
intention isn't the most important thing
for utilitarian what I was saying was
the transience of moral theories where
the intention or the motive is the most
like what we're going to study you know
Kant's deontology Cruiser or virtue
ethics to a certain extent you know the
intention or the motive is very
important you look at why somebody does
the things they do for utilitarian what
matters most are the consequences and
the why of it is measured in movies like
the consequences so I mean if somebody
had a motive like well I wanted to
produce as much pleasure as possible
that would be just fine
usually we don't think of these things
so directly in terms of pleasures Panza
who's talking about people being
motivated by well or friendship or
religion you know when we ask what makes
somebody tick what makes them do the
things that they do what makes them act
the way that they do where we ask this
about groups right
what makes that clique or that group or
that community a community where we ask
this about institutions what makes the
army act the way the does what makes the
town of Poughkeepsie whatever their
council is what makes Marist College you
know Frank for example Marist is really
devoted to sustainability and being
green and all that stuff that would be
an example of a moment that one would
say that's all fine does it produce more
pleasure than pain that's all we really
care about in the end so motives are are
measured in terms of their capacity to
produce pleasures and pains the last
thing that he talks about in the stuff
that we read for today is dispositions
and we have used this term very much
before but you guys are already familiar
with if you have a disposition to do
something that's a tendency yeah right
so you all have a disposition to show up
here at the eight o'clock in the morning
and that's why you're here some of you
think about it each day I really need to
go to class the asset
glass most of you I think don't most of
you get up and do whatever it is that
you do in the morning brush your teeth
comb your hair take a shower put up some
clothes eat breakfast or go to eat
breakfast and you get up in here and
boom class starts and it's underway
before you do that you thought about
anything right do something later
especially the warning right where
you've got these sort of habits set up
and you guys have set up these habits
for a long time because you hear all
upperclassmen so you've been doing this
College thing for a while and actually
some of you may find yourself waking up
too early once you're on Thanksgiving
break because you're used to eight
o'clock classes so you're gonna find
yourself waking up at 8 o'clock and then
say oh wait a second I don't have to go
to class you have a disposition it's
sort of like being set in motion
you know until something changes your
course you're you've got that inertia
it's the same way with moral actions we
have dispositions some of us are more
naturally we're not yet in the second
nature
courageous we're willing to stand up for
what we think is right others are less
like some of us fly off the handle too
easily they're bad dispositions when it
comes to anger some of us are more
patient with other people some of us are
maybe two nations
we never get angry right we talked about
this with the Arizona virtues advices
our dispositions
what does bentham tell us about
dispositions I think you can probably
guess so
tensions and we also have this broader
thing of disposition or habits or
another thing you can think of is
character would that go into action
though this is a way of producing right
that's a good question if you think
about this if you have a disposition for
a certain type of behavior you're not
actually doing it all the time right so
if you have a disposition or it's
self-indulgence that doesn't mean that
you're always performing that action the
action comes out of the disposition in
circumstances or if you have a good
disposition with respect to temperature
moderation in a certain stunts are being
moderate all the time right by not
eating all the time we're not drinking
all the time but it's really only when
you have an occasion and you have to
exercise self-control if you if you're
an angry person that doesn't mean you're
actually angry all the time
that's a disposition getting angry you
shouldn't get in you're holding grudges
that would be
the action that expresses the
disposition everybody that's a good
question to answer about the difference
between the action and a disposition so
what do you think Bentham's idea about
dispositions what makes them good or bad
because we took a look at some
dispositions as good as well as bad like
somebody who's greedy that a bitter bad
thing yeah we look at it that that's
they're a bad person all right or think
of all the think of the seven deadly
sins right what are the other greedy
lustful what's up buggy legal Optus I
guess would be the adjective swath full
to be lazy wrathful that 5vi
so we're missing to be prideful nobody
likes prideful people right there
they're okay in the bureau you start
telling a story they've got a better
story than yours
what's the anyone remember what the
other one was anybody right
an enemy that's kind of an ugly trying
to isn't it hard to get away from I know
I feel envious myself sometimes when I
see the success of my my peers I don't
like I know it's a bad disposition but
is it really that's the way they tend to
think of things now let's look at it as
utilitarian let's take enemy right
what's won't be out about envy you care
too much about what other people they
don't have an appreciation for yourself
okay how you're doing so could bring me
pain I feel like mad
yeah yeah that's it we didn't have to
look at in terms of cannon cutter entity
is actually feeling pain at somebody
else's success good things right the
envious of another person means that you
actually feel bad because they're doing
well
is that so bad
this could envy bring about any good
consequences yeah I mean think about our
economy a lot of its based on this being
motivated by wanting to have what the
the other person has to sort of put
yourself back up on their level that
drives our economy maybe that's a good
thing because what are the alternatives
what are the other possibilities well
you could go back to the you know the
Middle Ages know do we want to be under
a command economy like communism all of
you picked your jobs if you were like in
communist China you don't pick your job
they pick your job for you
they want you to do it probably started
with near bottom start setting for a 4/5
around that track maybe um because I'm
not actually saying that this is true
I'm just putting this out there's a line
of argument maybe Envy as a disposition
from the Athenian perspective could
actually be a good thing
ramp is a harder one to do the Greek
consider that right you've all heard
that that famous speech greed is good
from Wall Street what was he saying he
was saying well greed is good because it
actually motivates us to try to produce
more and ultimately that will produce
more plungers now you could do good
contestants and not imagine things but
my pains because it's things up what do
you actually focusing on consequences
right everything for you two three
utilitarian has to ultimately be
evaluated in terms of consequences in
terms whether it overall creates
pleasure or overall creates pain there's
nothing that's good or bad in and of
itself no motive no disposition
no intention by itself is automatically
good if you add no action is
automatically good or bad you actually
have to look at what it's likely
consequences are this is a very
different way of looking at human wrath
like our government but its wrath on the
Middle East to get out in what hmm that
was a good thing brought a lot of people
pleasure and then bought that pain but
it played it out wait good tape buddy
hunter that's greedy and you're greedy
saying like okay you know I want
everybody my company
Wow yeah some be greedy you know not
necessarily a bad thing but if you're
just greedy by 1 billion dollars I'm
going to you know kill everybody who
disagrees with me then you know that'd
be bad yeah it depends very much on how
it manifests itself in action and what
consequences it leads it's interesting
you bring up these these policy things
because oftentimes as Americans we look
at civic war in terms of our casualties
and we do a cost-benefit analysis was
the Iraq war worth it we look at how
many Americans died we tend to only
focus it up and military people not all
the other people that we brought over
there
all these mercenaries that we hired who
died as well and then we balance it
against the costs those are all clause
and we say what benefit did it bring us
while we're keeping the war over there
Rajini or safer over here that's worth
what are we missing
what are we not focus on their pain yeah
they have anybody else out think about
the first Iraq war not just this one
we've got into the first Iraq war it was
it was seen as desert amazing success
because we only have about 100
casualties a lot of those were friendly
fire how many Iraqis actually died when
we named all people and we carpet bombed
the Iraqi army they were the bunkers we
dropped bombs on them and steal hundreds
of thousands of people into martyrs we
Zieve that up at a utilitarian wouldn't
do that and utilitarian you have to
actually look at the picture we don't
need you on this thing actually you can
think of it there's a guy out there
Peter Singer yeah he is a contemporary
utilitarian I think he may have heard me
mention it before he would broaden it
even to include animals so we were going
to think about hippies me eating cows
right maybe we would have to take into
account pleasure and pain that is felt
by those animals I wouldn't go so far as
yeah I'm not actually still carrying
myself and I think there's a lot of
utilitarians out there that think that
human beings are somehow you know more
importantly
yeah although I think they do bring
something like speaking about kosher
butchering where they pull it up by the
leg that's a good question the the
kosher laws insofar as I understand are
largely focused maintaining the proper
relationship between the human being and
creation using creation in the right way
so the butchering is supposed to the way
to do it as a to pull the animal off
cause it cuts throat blood runs on the
ideas you're not supposed to be
consuming blood and it has a side effect
being in some ways a more humane way of
butchering than what we do in our
slaughterhouses where Isis cattle coming
through and some guy with essentially a
gun who puts it up to the cow's head
push the button goes into the cattle
Stein kills it and the cattle can
actually see on the other cattle get
killed by the way they don't like it so
in a way from a utilitarian perspective
kosher butcher could be more humane so
that could be a good thing it would
really depend on whether you're
considering the animals pleasure some
utility or some utilitarians like Peter
Singer let's say you have two other
utilitarians and say you should but most
of these military ins are actually again
if they're for an animal stuff they're
usually against killing
because that's gonna care about pain
then usually the ways in which we raise
them ultimately to kill them to leave
unfilled cages right that's what I'm a
media that that cheery thought--
I'll see you Monday and then we'll sneak
up with John Stuart Mill equality